i'm jesse
and this is my suitcase but before i
show you what i've got inside
i'm going to make a very public
confession
and that is
i'm outfit obsessed
i love finding wearing
and more recently photographing and
blogging a different colorful crazy
outfit for every single occasion
but i don't buy anything new
i get all my clothes secondhand from
flea markets and thrift stores
oh thank you
secondhand shopping allows me to reduce
the impact my wardrobe has on the
environment
and on my wallet i get to meet all kinds
of great people
my dollars usually go to a good cause i
look pretty unique
and it makes shopping like my own
personal treasure hunt i mean what am i
going to find today is it going to be my
size will i like the color
will it be under 20
if all the answers are yes i feel as
though i've won
i want to get back to my suitcase
and tell you what i packed for this
exciting week here at ted i mean what
what does somebody with all these
outfits bring with her so i'm going to
show you exactly what i brought
i brought
seven pairs of underpants
and that's it
exactly one week's worth of undies is
all i put in my suitcase i was betting
that i'd be able to find everything else
i could possibly want to wear once i got
here to palm springs
and since you don't know me as the woman
walking around ted in her underwear
that means i found a few things
and i'd really love to show you my
week's worth of outfits right now does
that sound good
so
as i do this i'm just gonna i'm also
gonna tell you a few of the life lessons
that believe it or not i have picked up
in these adventures wearing nothing new
so let's start with sunday
i call this shiny tiger you do not have
to spend a lot of money to look great
you can almost always look phenomenal
for under fifty dollars this whole
outfit including the jacket cost me 55
and it was the most expensive thing that
i wore the entire week
monday
color is powerful it is almost
physiologically impossible to be in a
bad mood when you're wearing bright red
pants
if you are happy you are going to
attract other happy people to you
tuesday
fitting in
is way overrated
i spent a whole lot of my life trying to
be myself and at the same time fit in
just be who you are if you are
surrounding yourself with the right
people they will not only get it they
will appreciate it
wednesday embrace your inner child
sometimes people tell me that i look
like i'm playing dress-up or that i
remind them of their seven-year-old
i like to smile and say thank you
thursday confidence is key
if you think you look good in something
you almost certainly do and if you don't
think you look good in something you're
also probably right
i grew up with a mom who taught me this
day in and day out but it wasn't until i
turned 30 that i really got what this
meant and i'm going to break it down for
you for just a second
if you believe
you're a beautiful person inside and out
there is no look that you can't pull off
so there is no excuse for any of us here
in this audience we should be able to
rock anything we want to rock
thank you
friday a universal truth five words for
you
gold sequins go with everything
and finally saturday
developing your own unique personal
style is a really great way to tell the
world something about you without having
to say a word it's been proven to me
time and time again as people have
walked up to me this week simply because
of what i'm wearing and we've had great
conversations
so obviously this is not all going to
fit back in my tiny suitcase so before i
go home to brooklyn i'm going to donate
everything back because the lesson i'm
trying to learn myself this week
is that it's okay to let go
i don't need to get emotionally attached
to these things because around the
corner there is always going to be
another crazy
colorful
shiny outfit just waiting for me
if i put a little love in my heart and
look
thank you very much
thank you